lady white am i alive you are a toy you
belong to Bonnie these are your friends
woody I have a question
well actually not just one I have all
the questions who wants to go on a road
trip you need help with that no no I got
it
I know this is a little strange but we
all have to make sure nothing happens to
four key but we gotta get poisoned Roger
that change of plans
Jesse ham but Rex potato hey watch it
let's go save us pork do I need to be
worried my guys are veteran so hang in
there
Oh
I know the perfect toy to help
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man
oh yeah posing yeah do quick hold on one
more oh yeah what you'll save me I've
known that guy my whole life today's
[Music]
is that how we look on the inside
there's so much body needs for kids Oh
Sheriff would you always come in to the
rescue that's gonna be quite a jump for
you and do for me let's kaboom
four keys being kept how do we get that
key what about the old plush rush there
you go oh where did you two come from
well we're not doing that
[Music]
you